[Musique]
il y a une sorte de retenue et donner
le maximum d'émotions imputées tu
sais oh comment peux-tu y parvenir comment puis-
je faire ça je ne sais pas c'est un mystère
non c'est en partie un mystère c'est en partie
c'est un mystère quand je vois  d'autres personnes le
font et je ne peux pas je ne peux pas imaginer comment
ils peuvent le faire quand je vois d'autres
actrices comme vous le dites ressentir une émotion et
mettre un plafond dessus pour qu'elle ne sorte
pas je je pourrais je pense comment  peuvent-ils
nous montrer et en même temps nous
cacher cette chose et je pense que je ne peux pas faire
ça je ne peux pas faire ça et pourtant
tu me poses la question comment je fais
donc je ne sais pas je  'ai eu je n'ai pas de
méthode pour m'entraîner je ne sais pas que tu
répètes je ne sais vraiment pas non
répéter n'aide pas vraiment mais cela
a beaucoup à voir avec le fait de faire semblant et comme les
enfants font semblant et jouent à être des rois
et des reines  et les cow-boys et les Indiens et
ils croient vraiment qu'ils sont ces
choses et j'y pense un peu
plus je crois que je suis ce que je suis quand
Je fais ça plus ça vient mais tu l'as
inventé tout seul ou c'est ta
formation au théâtre et différente
tu as des professeurs de toute façon oh non j'ai eu des
professeurs beaucoup de professeurs oui ils ne peuvent pas
t'apprendre ça alors ils peuvent ils peuvent
enseigner  vous toutes les choses qui
soutiennent qu'ils vous enseignent la structure qui
maintient cela et le maintient pendant des
heures et des heures et des heures et ils
vous apprennent à vous maintenir votre
technique d'endurance
pour soutenir votre talent artistique,
mais ils ne peuvent pas je  Je ne peux pas vous donner cette
autre chose le talent artistique que vous obtenez de
votre mère et de votre père Je ne sais pas
où vous l'obtenez c'est magique donc une autre
question incontournable pourrait être le
problème des stars féminines au cinéma
aujourd'hui non vous y pensez c'est un
joli coup voulez-vous en être un voulez-vous
en être un bien est-ce possible ouais je
ne sais pas comment être un B je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait plus une sorte de star
je pense que les stars sont les interprètes
Liza Minnelli est une  étoile Barbra Stré  isand
est une star mais je ne vois pas comment un vrai acteur
un vrai acteur peut être une star si c'est si
vous êtes un acteur transformant quelqu'un
intéressé par la polyvalence et se déplaçant
d'un endroit à l'autre avec une surprise à laquelle
vous ne pouvez pas attacher de personnalité  cette
personne, je veux dire, ce n'est pas quelque chose que vous pouvez
vénérer, vous savez comme une déesse ou
quelque chose que je ne peux pas faire, je ne peux pas être
ça, donc je dois être ce que je suis, je dois
être un acteur qui travaille, je suis le meilleur de toute façon
ben oui fais du mieux que je peux faire et peu
importe où ça me mène je pense
que ça te mène à décevoir les
gens si tu le fais vraiment bien je pense
forcément
un jour tu joues un rôle que les gens ils
n'aiment pas ça c'est pas elle c'est
pas comme elle est et c'est probablement
le jour où tu réussis le mieux en tant qu'acteur
c'est quand ils disent ça
[Musique]